[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
nice enough
just a man
to keep them alive
[Music]
face the face
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
i am
i'm
i paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
[Music]
oh
my friends
[Music]
we are the champions
[Music]
i've taken my bout
[Music]
but it's been
[Music]
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
oh
and now the end
and is i face
the final curtain
my friend i'll say it clear
i'll state my case
of which i'm certain
i've lived a life that's full
i traveled each and
every highway
and more much more than this
i did it my
regrets i've had a few
[Music]
but then again
too few to mention
i did what i
had to do
saw it through without
exemption i planned
each charted course each cap will step
along the byway
and more much more than this
i did it my
way yes there were times
i'm sure you knew
when i fit off more than i could choose
but do it all
when there was doubt
[Music]
and i stood tall
[Music]
i've had my filled
my share of losing
and now as tears subside
i find it all so
amusing to think
i did all that
and may i say
not in a shy way
oh no oh no
not me i did it
[Music]
my way
is a man
what has he got
[Music]
if not himself
then he has not to say
the things he truly feels
[Music]
[Music]
yes it was
my way
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the fires
[Music]
be
[Music]
just made it
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
feed it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
just
she packed my bags last night every
flight
zero hour nine a.m
[Music]
i miss the earth so much i miss my wife
it's lonely out of space on such a
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time brings me round and get too
fine
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
alone
in fact it's cold as hell
and there's no one there to raise them
if
[Music]
is
[Music]
a rocket
and i think man gonna be a long long
time brings me round again
[Music]
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
[Music]
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
and i think it's gonna be a long time
is
[Music]
speaker it's bigger
than you and you are not me
the links that i will go to
the distance in your eyes
oh no i've said too
much i set it up
[Music]
that's me in the corner
trying to
[Music]
and i keep know if i could do it
oh no i've said it too
much i haven't said enough
i thought that i heard you laughing
i thought that i heard
[Music]
i think i thought i saw you
trying
to keep my eye on you
like a hurt lost
[Music]
consider this
[Music]
[Music]
i thought that i heard you laughing
i thought
i think i thought i saw you
trying
that was just a dream
that was just a dream that's me in the
corner
that's
[Music]
can do it i'm now
sad too much
i haven't said enough
i thought that i heard you say you
try
[Music]
just a dream tree
[Music]
do
[Music]
just a small town girl
living in a lonely world
[Music]
he took
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they can share the night it goes on and
on and on
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
somewhere
working hard to get my feel
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
and on and on
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
be
don't stop me
don't stop
one
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
foreign
which is
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
give us
and forgive us
as we
[Music]
and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
and the glory
[Music]
wow
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
is
if i don't change the pace
[Music]
tucson tower air force one
air force one tucson tower
tucson tower air force one we are on
final approach
air force one tucson tower you are clear
to land
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
the first time
the last time we ever
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back on the street
[Music]
so many times it happened too fast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you wanna
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
straight to the top
[Music]
what's the distance
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i'll
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
day
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
my
[Music]
baby
[Music]
baby
is
[Music]
he got to be the leader
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you that
he's a [ __ ] man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
please please please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
oh
[Music]
please
wanna please
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
take my hand
[Music]
i wanna be
i love you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
next to
[Music]
god
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains and texas
[Music]
we stand and save
where it
[Music]
you and is her still today
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the usa
[Music]
from the days of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas right down
into houston
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go down
oh thank you thank you what a crowd wow
wow thank you dusan
thank you tousan wow
well thank you very much your son i'm
thrilled to be in arizona with the
thousands of loyal
hard-working american patriots
15 days from now we're going to win the
state of arizona
and we are going to win four more
years in that beautiful white house
[Applause]
everybody needs to get out and vote
return your absentee ballot
or vert you know you can go out there i
think today when do you do it today
tomorrow whatever you can go and vote
today they say today go out and vote
that beats a ballot do you agree that
beats a ballot
remember the old-fashioned days when
you'd actually go out and vote today
they send you
millions of ballots are you okay over
there everyone fine good
okay he looks better than i do that guy
he looks better than i do good
thank you you make sure you're okay with
your vote we'll continue to cut your
taxes and regulations
maintain energy independence which we
have now
strengthen our military support our
police protect our
second amendment
don't know i don't see you people i
don't think you're going to want to give
up those guns i don't think so
that's not that's not for arizona
defend our borders arrest violent
criminals and confirm
more judges to uphold the rule of law
[Applause]
under my leadership prosperity will
surge what we've done in the last three
and a half years has been incredible
nobody's ever done what we've done there
is no administration that's accomplished
what we've accomplished in the first
three and a half years
not even twice
optimism world boom the pandemic it's
rounding the turn
vaccines are coming and i look fine
don't i you know
[Applause]
and we'll get back to a normal life
that's what we want just the normal just
seven months ago we want to get back
it will be better than that very soon we
built a foundation that's so strong
and you see what's happening stock
market through the roof
your 401ks through the roof your stocks
through the roof you're housing through
the roof everything is good
your optimism and what about 56 of the
people
just a gallup poll just came out 56
of the people say they're better off
today
than they were four years ago and we
have a pandemic
[Applause]
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country that's what's going to happen
we're cutting your taxes they're raising
your taxes that's uh
an easy one to figure out isn't it this
election is a choice between
a trump super recovery or abiding
depression
if he even gets to run
it's a choice between getting a safe
vaccine and getting back in and working
and by the way you have a governor here
today he's done a great job and he's
kept you open
you're open unlike some of them like
michigan
you know we won the case in michigan you
know the only one that was allowed to
have a good time was the governor's
husband
he was allowed to do whatever the hell
he wanted but nobody else they were like
in a prison
but we're gonna have a safe vaccine and
uh biden you know what he's gonna do
lock him down let's lock everybody down
but we built the greatest economy ever
we had to close it down we saved
millions of lives by doing what we did
then we built it back up
and now we're doing record type numbers
and it's a choice between the american
dream or a socialist nightmare that's
what it is
biden will delay therapies postpone the
vaccine prolong the pandemic
close your schools and shut down our
country
and we're opening and we're opening
rapidly and we've got a v-shape
it may be a super-v it looks like it's a
super-v
which nobody ever even heard of before
he will massively raise your taxes bury
your record you will be buried in
regulations you know we cut regulations
it would take 18 to 21 years to get a
highway approved
we have it down to one year and you know
what
from two to one we're very shortly to be
exact right now it's less than two we're
gonna have it down to one year and it
may get rejected
for environmental reasons or safety and
that's okay probably not
but that's okay but you know what you're
going to have it approved or not
approved
and it's a one-year process not a
21-year process
and this has gone on all over the
country and in my opinion
what we've done on regulations is even
more important
than the biggest tax cut in the history
of our country i think it's more
important
and they're going to bring all those
regulations back
they want to dismantle your police
departments
dissolve your borders dissolve your
borders if you don't have borders you
don't have a country
confiscate your guns ban american energy
wipe out private health care 180 million
people terminate religious liberty
this is for the women the women who live
in the suburbs they want to destroy your
suburbs
and i ended the rule that was going to
destroy
i ended the regulation that was going
i kept hearing that women from the
suburbs won't like trump i said why
because i'm stopping crime
you're going to have suburbs be safe
suburbs you're having safe
suburbs and you're not going to have low
income housing projects built next to
your house
we ended the regulation that would have
destroyed your suburbs
it's amazing how the women like me all
of a sudden
and as you know the democrats they want
to cut
our military to the bone and we built
the greatest military right now
in the history of our country frankly in
the history of the world
biden will surrender your jobs to china
he will surrender your future to the
virus
and he will surrender your country to
the radical
socialist left and you see that
happening
the only thing biden wants to do is get
as much as he can for himself have you
been watching this whole thing player
i didn't know anything about it oh
here's a picture of biden playing golf
with these people
i didn't know my son was taking money
from
barista i didn't know my son got three
and a half billion dollars from
the mayor of moscow's wife i wonder why
and then you see all the things right
that
we have to give the man 10 we have to
give the man
10 right oh boy
i'll tell you what nobody's ever seen
and the media right and big tech
they won't they won't allow it
charlie kirk you know charlie kirk great
guy
they shut down his site because he
mentioned it
look he's a corrupt politician this guy
he's a corrupt politician
to get the power biden has made a
corrupt bargain in exchange for his
party's nomination
he has handed control of his party over
to the
socialists the communists the marxists
and the left-wing
extremists and that's before we get to
his own personal corruption
which is more than anybody in history
i say this it's the second biggest
scandal politically in the history of
our country
number one was spying on my campaign and
getting caught
[Applause]
biden even shows as his running mate the
most liberal senator in america
kamala kamala
senator kamala harris is a sponsor of
the socialist green new deal
and legislation to strip away the
private health plans
of 180 million americans and you know
her and bernie sanders want to do
something in arizona they have some deal
in arizona where
your taxes are going to go way up you
know that right
your governor who's right over here your
great governor was saying
he's not happy with it but bernie
sanders the second most liberal person
you know she's first right she's
considered
they want to raise your taxes eight and
a half percent so i'm glad
that governor he's saying more
it's probably more what is the name of
that governor royal what
right you know about it okay you can't
have them in because they control
biden 100 biden is shot you know he's
shot right
these gunzo harris also urged their
supporters to donate to a fund
that bailed out the riot as the ones
that knocked out your towns your cities
not in republican areas by the way all
in democrat areas
you look at portland how about that we
would have taken 15 minutes we could
have solved that
we told the governor democrat let us in
we'll solve that problem
we went into minneapolis it took us a
half an hour that was over with
unfortunately they could have called a
little earlier
and in seattle they gave up when they
heard we were going in the next morning
but we would tell look all democrat
areas new york going to hell i feel so
sad with new york
crime is up 200 250 cuomo
a terrible thing has happened in new
york look at chicago
democrat again crime is through the roof
that a weekend
87 people were shot and 16 died
okay now do you believe this isn't hey
we're in afghanistan you don't lose
many people we're coming out by the way
it's all coming we're all coming back
home
but you go to war zones you don't have
that
and we could solve it so easily
thank you thank you
thank you you know there's never been
that chance before seriously
we all like ronald reagan i guess he'd
be but
he never had that share we love you
thank you dad we love you
you're going to make me cry don't do
that i don't want to cry
i don't want to cry
[Music]
make me cry you'll destroy my image and
then you won't love me anymore that'll
be terrible
i appreciate it now i do and i feel the
same way that's why i'm doing this i had
a good life before i did this stuff
believe me my life was very simple and
very nice
the democrat parties warren cops is
inciting riots and putting police
officers and american families in very
grave danger
unlike joe biden i will always support
the heroes of law enforcement
[Music]
and i was endorsed by almost every
law enforcement group in the united
states
including new york's finest and chicago
and
florida and texas and oklahoma and every
place
and i was just named i have to say this
happened today the man of the year in
their big magazine the blue magazine
good name for
man of the year so i just tell you that
for whatever reason
i'm the only one standing between you
and a
left-wing crusade you know you have
people they want to change our whole
country
and the thing that's going to bring us
back together a success
because i'll tell you we were ready i
was getting calls
seven months ago we had the best
employment numbers we ever had
with the greatest success we've ever had
we were beating china at everything you
know you kept hearing about
we were beating everybody and they were
calling me people that i wouldn't be
speaking to
generally let's get together it was
happening and then we got hit by the
china plague
and then we had to start all over again
but it will success brings us together
i saw it and i we saw it for two months
it was really going on
a new study of the biden harris agenda
found that their
plans will crater the typical american
family
by more than six thousand five hundred
dollars their horrible horrible plans to
finance what the blue
the new the new green deal
the green new deal is the craziest thing
right no more airplanes no more double
cars
no more cows if you have a ranch you
won't have cows anymore
no more you you'll be next in just three
years i
increased family income by six thousand
dollars
and we're not even talking about the
energy did you ever think you'd be
seeing two dollar gasoline again and you
got that
and it's plentiful and we saved all our
energy jobs
all of our energy jobs we say biden will
eviscerate the middle class my policies
will lift
the middle class to record highs and
that's where we're going very quickly
for the last 47 years sleepy joe biden
shipped away your jobs
shut down your factories threw open your
borders
and ravaged our cities while sacrificing
american blood and treasure in these
endless ridiculous
foreign wars in countries you never even
heard of
joe biden is a servant of the left-wing
globalists and lobbyists
the wealthy donors the washington
vultures
who got rich bleeding america dry you
know they raise a lot of money the
democrats you know why because they make
deals
they make deals i would be the greatest
fundraiser in history if i wanted to
call wall street i know them all
i want 10 million dollars for my
campaign yes sir all i have to say is i
want 10 million i want 15 i want 25.
i would set every record but you know
what happens when you do that you're
selling yourself out
when you have to do something you can't
do it anymore
because you feel guilty
you see them setting all sorts of
records i know what the records are the
records
every time they set a record they gave
away everything in 2016 you voted to
fire this corrupted decrepit political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting america first
it's about time joe biden as always
and always has been a corrupt politician
joe biden is a corrupt politician
and you know what you knew that and a
lot of people knew it for a long time
but now you have the laptop it's over
it's over
and as far as i'm concerned the biden
family is a
criminal enterprise and that's what it
is a criminal enterprise
smoking gun emails shown we just found
them you saw that
did you see a shifty shift we think that
the uh laptop was made by
russia oh i see oh
oh he just said it was made by russia
here we go again russia did it russia
russia russia
you know the head of dni john ratchliff
was fantastic came out and said
that was false information now these are
bad people these are sick people
do you notice they never say it was made
by china
because they're all on the tank
smoking gun email show just came out
that the biden family used the vice
presidency as a for-profit cash machine
and that joe biden has been lying to the
american public to cover it up
remember he said no i never met anybody
from barista is it is it barista
actually that i understand because he's
got no memory left it's gone
is it barista no i don't read and then
they show a picture of him playing golf
with the head of barista
ah boy oh boy if biden wins
china wins and china will own
the usa remember what i said
the media and big tech is trying to hide
the entire scandal do you believe what
they're doing
they're taking people like a charlie
kirk and others off
if they even mention that biden is
corrupt
and they know he's corrupt but he's
there corrupt he's so perfect for them
he's there corrupt because they know
that publicizing these
revelations would mean an end of biden's
presidential run i think it's an end
right now look
you know i think it's an end right now
how the hell can you do when you see the
kind of things that
they do where the big guy has to get at
least 10
the big guy i wonder who the big guy is
t i wonder
when you see what if you put him as
president you should be ashamed of
yourselves you want to know the truth
i'm not just running against biden
i'm running against the left-wing media
the big tech giants
and the washington swamp and i've been
running against it from the beginning
and here i am all by myself it's truly
oh yeah yeah anybody else that would
have been in a corner right now
thumb in mouth saying mommy take me home
mommy i want to go home
now it's uh it's great you know why it's
great though because nobody's ever done
what we've done
[Applause]
nobody
[Applause]
they flood your communities with
criminal aliens
drugs and crime while they live behind
beautiful
gated communities they try to take away
your guns
while they enjoy private security fully
armed by the way
how fully armed how about bloomberg we
are fighting guns and he's got five guys
around him with guns
they support crippling lockdowns while
their jobs and their industry remain
totally exempt it's time to send a
message
to these wealthy liberal hypocrites in
washington and in silicon valley
show them the american people are in
charge by delivering
their chosen candidate sleepy joe biden
who shouldn't even be their candidate
he should have lost because elizabeth
pocahontas warren
if she would have dropped out the day
before super tuesday
joe would have lost every single state
to crazy bernie it's a very simple
business but we have to show them the
democrats a thundering defeat
on november 3rd
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you harder
than anyone has ever fought for you
which is true and i'm fighting so hard i
had a great life
i'm fighting so hard because i love my
country
and because i'm determined to ensure
that the forgotten
men and women of this country are never
forgotten
again and they won't be they won't be
and we talked that lesson to him four
years ago but we're gonna teach him
again because this is the most important
you know i used to go a few months ago
say well i don't know this is
important that's important which is more
important this is the most important
election in the history of our country
the biden agenda would be a catastrophe
for
arizona seniors do we have any seniors
in the house
biden is pledging mass amnesty and free
federal health care for illegal aliens
you saw that
where he was up on the stage with his
radical left democrats
who's willing to give free health care
to illegal immigrants right they said to
illegal immigrants
right and everybody raised their hand
and biden couldn't get us up
because he knew you know he's been doing
this crap for 47 years right
he's gone he couldn't he knew it was
wrong but then he looked
and his brain is shot so he looked over
there and the hands were all up then he
looked over there and the hands were all
up
there were a lot of them he knew it was
wrong because it would be
so horrible for our country because
everyone's going to flood our country
you get free healthcare
right you get free healthcare you get
free education
i jokingly said everybody gets a rolls
royce
and cnn said that's a lie so what
happened is he couldn't get it up and
then he looked and he looked and he got
it up
and i said thank you we just won the
election
he would decimate medicare if he did
that
and it's not going to be up to him
that's his party that's what they want
they want socialized medicine
and he'll destroy your social security
while i'm president no one will touch
your medicare or your social security
you know the amazing thing biden's
always complaining oh he didn't stop
china fast enough except he didn't want
to stop him at all you know little
things like this
but you know he's always complaining and
yet he was here for 47 years
right i said joe joe it's not like
you're an outsider and it wasn't that
long ago either
47 years and all he does is complain
biden had 47 years to fight for seniors
and reduced prescription drug costs and
look what i've done and i've just
exercised they're going to come down 70
80 90 percent because i just did
something that
nobody thought anybody would do a
favorite nation's flaws we paid the
lowest in the world
you'll see numbers that are shocking
they're not happy with me the big pharma
big pharma is spending a lot of money
when you see those ads please remember
every one of those ads means your drug
prices are coming down
they can't believe it i tried to make a
deal with them i did i tried
but we couldn't in the end we couldn't
it got too greedy too much money
too much money but you know last year we
brought drug prices down
one percent i'm not bragging about it's
the first time in 52 years that drug
prices came down
but now we're going for the big one now
we're going for the big one
and you know rebates you know the
richest people the middlemen you know
the middlemen about drugs you know that
we have middlemen nobody knows who the
hell they are i never hear middle women
i hear middlemen so
we'll make it politically correct
middlemen no they're called middlemen
nobody knows who they are these guys are
so rich
who are they i'll bet you hunter gets a
piece of the action did they
hunter biden is a middleman on top of
everything else
he gets it from china he gets it from
ukraine
he got three and a half million from
russia from moscow
he got three and a half and on top of
everything else he's a middle man
no i'll bet he is he probably gets a
piece of the action but instead he sold
seniors out
to the drug lobby into big pharma that's
biden senior
i'm taking on the powerful special
interests like never before
nobody's ever done this before
nobody's ever done it before i mean you
know for years you heard about drug
prices nobody ever did anything
and now you hear about drug prices and
they're dropping they're going to be
dropping like a rock
also i'm letting your governor your
great governor
buy until the thing kicks in and
probably litigation
but you know i've exercised this whole
thing with favored nations so
if germany pays 10 cents for a pill and
we're paying two and a half dollars and
you have that kind of disparities
ridiculous
that we have the right to match in other
words we get the lowest price but until
it kicks in
canada pays half of what we pay so i'm
letting your governor and other
governors go to canada buy your drugs
through canada
save 50 percent we get rid of the
middlemen
the other thing we did very big much
less than what we're talking about but
very big we capped insulin costs for
medicine and medicare
for medicare plans at less than 35
dollars a month people were dying
because they couldn't afford insulin
33 million seniors 33 think of this
35 but 33 million seniors
on medicare will soon be receiving
200 to help with their drug course on
top of everything else
nobody's done by the way in all fairness
nobody has done anything like this
but your big thing your big thing is
going to be when you see what happens
with the favored nations because you've
been hearing about it for years
where other countries are paying a tiny
fraction of what we we bear all of the
costs
because our politicians sold us out
they sold us out but i'm not a
politician so it's one of the
i couldn't stand watching it to battle
the china virus
we launched the largest mobilization
since world war
ii our early and aggressive action saved
more than two million lives
i acted early to ban travel from
china and tr how about this you should
have done it sooner but in the meantime
when i did it he called me xenophobic
right and then months later he agreed
that i was right
and now he's saying i should have done
it sooner this guy
i also banned it from europe because i
saw with italy and with spain
and with france and by the way they have
a big spike right now
they have a very big spike right now and
we're doing good
we are rounding the turn we have the
vaccines coming and all but even without
we're rounding the turn
people are pandemic out you know that
they're pandemiced out
that's why it's so great what your
governor's done he's opened up your
state you're doing great
we pioneered life's and by the way you
get it
you know like i say here i am i'm here
i'm here and now i'm immune i can jump
into this audience and kiss
every man and woman i'm a mural
[Applause]
right they say
it used to be your immune for life and
then when i got it i said i'm immune
they said it's only good for four months
see if anybody
you understand that right i'll jump into
that audience right there
[Applause]
we pioneered life-saving therapies and
reduced the fatality rate
85 think of it and i had it too i didn't
feel good
i feel not so great and i'm not used to
that
and we can't let that happen to a
president because we not we have to be
at the top of our game that's why you
can't let
biden be president because he's not at
the top of this game mentally
can't have that one thing i can tell you
putin president xi of china
kim jong-un all of them macron they're
very much at the top of their game you
can't let this happen to our country
you can't but i was sitting i was lying
and you know if you're president
one thing you're guaranteed lots of
doctors and they would grab me
they grabbed me by every part they had
hands all over me i said get the hell
out of here i just don't feel good
and we ended up i used the drug
regeneron which nobody ever
thought about six months ago and i woke
up the next morning and i was like i
felt like superman
get me out of here i said get me out of
here
and eli lilly makes a similar product
and we're going to distribute that we're
trying to get emergency use so we can do
it faster
because it's early but it's fantastic
antibodies
and we're going to distribute it all
over and we're going to make sure that
people that have a problem that get the
same drug
as i got and i'm telling you it'll be
the same result
it'll be the same result and it's free
we're going to do it free companies are
working with us
because it's not their fault it's
china's fault it's not their fault
but i woke up and i felt good i said get
me out of here boom superman
through operation warp speed we will
have 100 million vaccine doses before
the end of the year
and our military is going to distribute
them and they are there's nobody like
our military
[Applause]
the vaccine will end the pandemic but
even without the vaccine
the pandemic is ending it's gonna end it
ends with it but you know this can this
can go quickly this can make it go a lot
faster biden's locked down
we'll crush america my plan will crush
the virus and bring back your american
dream
[Applause]
so we're joined today by some very
special people
a friend of mine somebody that's been
with me from the beginning i've been
with him from the beginning
he's very difficult because when he
needs something for the state like money
he'll call me all the time i say doug do
me a favor give me a break
but i guess that's what you're supposed
to do right that's what you want he's
supposed to call and
finally i'll say all right doug you got
it get out of here promise not to call
then he'll call me two weeks later i
need more
but he's a great governor one of the
greatest governors he's done a fantastic
job you're down to very low numbers by
the way
doug ducey doug please
and we want you to vote for martha
mcsally
save your second amendment save your
second amendment
doug you want to come up come up doug
come here for a second
come on doug i'll tell you this guy has
been a great guy i don't know if you
like him tonight i don't care he's been
a great governor
donald trump will win arizona
donald trump will be re-elected
president of the united states
and along with donald trump and mike
pence
martha mcsally on november 3rd will join
them in the u.s
senate
mr president because of your policies
arizona's economy is booming
our home values are rising faster
than anywhere else in the nation and amy
coney barrett will be confirmed to the
supreme court
joe biden is wrong for america
joe biden would lock us down
joe biden would reduce your income 65
hundred dollars
and joe biden would make washington dc
estate
and and how many presidents of the
united states
would protect arizona by talking about
what bernie sanders
wants to do here by endorsing prop 208
wanting to raise our taxes 77
so on november 3rd vote no on prop 208
and vote yes for donald trump and mike
pence
to go back to the white house
thank you doug he's a great governor
he's a great great governor what a job
he's done and you know what we're not
going to take her time or anything but
martha mcsally is here she's saving your
second amendment
she's been a great great senator martha
come here honey
she's been a great great senator and
just go out
and vote for martha mcsally save
your second amendment save your second
thank you i'll see you down here thank
you darling
she's done a great job and she's a
worker and she's a great fighter pilot
they told me all about her some of the
pilots they said she was a great fighter
pilot
so thank you martha thank you thank you
doug
we also have a congressional candidate
that they say
is a star in the making i've heard it
from a lot of people
vote for brandon martin where's brandon
brandon good luck man i hear it's going
going good
good thank you brandon brandon martin
thank you brandon you're gonna do great
i heard you're doing really well
under my administration we built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world
and now we're doing it again you know
it's make america great again right i
say
make america great again again again
again
we did it and now we had to do it again
it's all right
it's happening and it's happening much
faster it looks like a super v
in my first three years we increased
family income more than five
times the gains in all eight years
under the last administration think of
that five times more
in the first three years five times more
than
eight years of the obama biden
administration that's not even
believable
african-american unemployment hispanic
american
unemployment asian american unemployment
all reached
record lows the lowest in the history of
our country we lifted 6.6 million
americans out of poverty
including more than 1.5 million
hispanic americans that's a record
and i'm doing very well in the polls
with hispanic americans but i always
like you and you always like me
the fake news just didn't know that our
policies are lifting up all americans of
every income
since the china virus we created 11.4
million american jobs it's a record too
nobody's ever seen anything like
you know the unemployment rate normally
i wouldn't be happy about this right but
the unemployment rate
a week ago hit 7.8 percent think of that
now
we were hearing 42 it's going to go to
42 it's going to go to 44. it's going to
go to 38.
7.8 and heading this way think of that
would you believe that normally i
wouldn't say it because we were at 3.4
3.5
and heading even better than that but
that's okay we'll be there soon
after the virus left china we experience
the smallest contraction of
any major western country and the
fastest
recovery anywhere in the world from
an economy standpoint
and we've already cut the unemployment
rate in less than half
that's a fantastic thing under biden and
obama it took over three and a half
years for arizona
to regain 60 percent of the jobs lost in
the crisis
and we've done it in four months think
of that
and it wasn't our fault wasn't our fault
manufacturing production
is up 61 retail sales are up
excuse me 121
[Applause]
that means more than before the pandemic
and automobile production nobody's gonna
believe this
one is up 350 percent
since april lows 350
i have a way that we can stop it elect
sleepy joe
no no you're for who has a 401k okay
so if i told you that your 401ks and
you're all at record highs are very
close right
if i told you that your 401ks will be
cut in half and much worse than that
that's what's going to happen you're
going to end up in a depression with
this guy
he's going to raise your taxes by four
or five times
and they're going to put on regulations
every company is going to say let's get
out of here
because i'll tell you the regulation
cuts which are more than anybody
than any administration has ever done
the regulation cuts
in their own way were more important
than the biggest tax cut in the history
of our country
thank you man as president i've been
delivering for
our incredible hispanic american
community like nobody has done before
[Music]
and i'm fighting for school choice safe
neighborhoods
and hispanic-owned small businesses
[Music]
joe biden would wipe out your small
businesses with lockdowns and
regulations
you know he said the other day oh i'd
lock it down oh great thanks a lot joe
we appreciate it
and devastate your families with massive
tax hikes
he will wage war on catholic
organizations
ban charter schools fund extreme
late term abortion
and he'll let socialists run wild
and we will never have a socialist
country
we will never have it we can't we won't
have a conflict
that's why we're going to win a record
share of the hispanic vote this november
get out and vote get out and vote
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding
foreign nations fighting foreign wars
defending foreign borders
but now we are finally protecting our
nation
rebuilding our cities we are protecting
our borders you know the wall is almost
finished right
our southern border and by the way the
biggest beneficiary maybe happens to be
arizona that wall how good is the wall
the governor was telling me before they
stopped coming in
now they come in they come in legally
now the wall is great goes down deep and
it goes up high
no more tunneling and we're bringing our
jobs our factories our troops back home
in the usa where they belong
right under my leadership we achieved
the most secure border
in u.s history our southern border is
now and i want to thank mexico mexico
has right now 27 000 troops guarding our
border how about that
and we've built almost 400 miles of the
wall
we're averaging about 10 miles a day and
it's the best
it's exactly what border patrol wanted i
said i'd like to just put up
i'd just like to put up concrete plank
they said no sir
we got to have it this way sir we gave
them the ultimate we gave them
everything they wanted and they're
really happy and it's had a huge impact
we've got the best we've got the best
border that we've ever had
and you know what you have a big chunk
of it right here and it's really
work you have 200 miles they tell me 200
miles
200 miles i didn't even know yet that's
a lot of mileage you're not paying a
damn
cent for it either all compliments of
the federal government right remember
when nancy pelosi they all said we don't
need a wall
walls are obsolete two things don't get
obsolete walls and wheels right
everything else is absolute you know
they developed a new chip yesterday in
about 15 minutes it's going to be
obsolete they developed a new computer
15 minutes obsolete
the two things that will never be
obsolete a wheel and a wall
remember the democrats they said no we
want drones we want drones so you can
have drones watching everybody pour into
the country
now 200 miles of wall in arizona and you
got it all
it's all done joe biden's party
continues to attack
our incredible border agents and they
are more than half of whom happen to be
hispanic americans i know a lot of them
right there yeah these are
guys here am i right right
the republican party will always stand
with the heroes of ice and border patrol
these are incredible people they're
doing an incredible job
my opponent's immigration plan is the
most extreme
proposal ever put forward biden's plan
would eliminate u.s borders
by implementing nationwide catching they
want nationwide
catch and really you know catch them
releases you catch them take their name
they could be murderers rapists and then
you release them into our country
guess what we don't do that anymore okay
that wasn't easy
[Music]
but it would have made every community
into and they want to make every
community
into a sanctuary city
and they want to suspend all removals of
illegal aliens so what they're doing and
this is done by
crazy bernie right you know bernie
sanders made a deal we call it the
manifesto
with joe biden and it's further left
than bernie ever was
joe did a great job of negotiation
supposed to bring him to the right he
brought him to the left
it would mean the total nullification of
u.s borders overwhelming every city in
town
in america ms-13 and criminal cartels
would rampage throughout our country
freely
if biden wins your borders are gone
which means your health care is gone
the middle class is gone and your safety
is gone other than that he's doing quite
a good job
from the moment i took office i worked
night and day to stop illegal
immigration it wasn't easy and now we've
got it
[Music]
and stopping it for arizona was a that
was a big deal
i ended catch and release i closed the
lobbyist loopholes
i took down the smugglers and coyotes
these are not nice people by the way
and i kept my promise to the american
people
we are finding the drug dealers all over
and we are arresting the drug dealers
like they have never been arrested
before we're finding the predators
we're finding the gang members we're
finding ms-13 killers
and we are either throwing them in jail
or sending them the hell
back home where they came from
[Applause]
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in our
military
we have the greatest equipment now
anywhere in the world
and you know when i first got here a
very highly overrated general told me
sir we have no ammunition
i said no president should ever hear
that we have no ammunition
truly this was a general who i didn't
have a lot of respect for
but he said we had no ammunition so i
said well
we're gonna have to do something we got
2.5 trillion dollars
we now are the envy of the world we have
weapons the likes of which
nobody in the world has russia china
nobody and for our vets we passed va
choice and va accountability
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
[Music]
and we took out the world's number one
terrorist and mass murderer
of american troops and many many people
salamani is dead
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous iran nuclear
deal
150 billion dollars 1.8 billion in cash
not the best deal it would have been
ending now almost anyway
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened
the american embassy in jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
they've been working on that for 52
years
i got it done in two hours
and instead of the endless wars we're
forging peace in the middle east no
blood in the sand
i did more in 47 months than joe biden
did in 47 years
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great jobs
a limitless future and for the american
dream it's for the american dream
remember you know the republican party
is the party of abraham lincoln right
the
party of america you know abraham
lincoln
i tell that to people they never know
they said gee i never knew that but
abraham honest abe was a special person
but in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing
power of the world and we will end our
reliance on china once and for all it's
already happening
we will hire more police increase
penalties for assaults and law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens and we will keep
america out of these ridiculous
foreign wars foreign wars
countries you've never even heard of
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require price transparency it's already
done it's all science starts on
january 1st it'll be more important
watch than healthcare
it'll be even more important i'm telling
you it's the numbers you're talking
about
price transparency remember further
reduce the cost of prescription drugs
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions always
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land
an astronaut on mars it's happening soon
and nasa is now the space center of the
world again
it was a mess we will stop the radical
indoctrination of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect our
great american flag
[Music]
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
[Music]
arizona
this is the most important
election in the history of our country
it's the most important i never thought
i'd be saying that
it's the most important
[Applause]
thank you very much very much appreciate
it
this is the most important election in
the history of our country and i never
did
i never thought i'd be saying that but
i'm seeing where these people want to
take us
they want to take us into a land that's
never worked
look at venezuela it's the same ideology
same philosophy
it's just a much bigger version but it
can happen we can't let it happen
the united states will never be a
socialist
nation can't happen
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
get your co-workers get your boss and
get out and vote
[Music]
from phoenix to flagstaff from mesa to
yuma
from tombstone what a great name to
right here in tucson
we stand on the shoulders of red-blooded
american patriots
who poured out their heart sweat and
soul
for our liberty and for our freedom
this great great great state i love this
state
i love this site now it's been you know
what arizona's been good to me from the
beginning
from the beginning from day one right we
had the big victory
my first speech was in arizona right
remember
phoenix remember that and we had this
big convention hall i said how the hell
are you gonna fill it
and we had that thing packed and there
were lines outside they couldn't get in
i said wow
and that's when the fake news started
saying what the hell is going on with
this trump guy right
remember that in phoenix the big
convention center was packed
and there were thousands and thousands
of people that was my first speech
and they started saying what's that all
about even i said what's that all about
right
but i'm glad we all did it we did it
together and this was the first place
arizona thank you very much
thank you this great state was settled
by some of the toughest men and
strongest women
ever to walk the face of the earth
arizona is where
wyatt earp and doc holliday became
american legends wyatt
is where the great american west became
the american dream
and arizona is the state where
generations of pioneers and prospectors
miners and ranchers cowboys and cattle
hands
marshals and lorman tame the frontier
brave the blazing sun like i'm doing
right now i'm gonna be like
you're gonna see me tomorrow i'm gonna
look like a lobster you're gonna say
look what we did to him
they said would you like to wear a hat i
said there's no way i'm wearing a hat i
got to show these
we got to show strength right frank
and showed the entire world how the west
was won this is it
they helped make america into the
greatest nation in the history of the
world
and the best is yet to come it's
happening
it's happened proud citizens like you
helped build this country and together
we are taking back our country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Applause]
[Music]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of arizona
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
stock market we have made america
strong again our military
[Applause]
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you very much thank
you arizona get out and vote
get out and vote thank you
[Music]
young man there's no need to feel down i
said a young man
you can stay there and i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
but you've got to know this
mca i'm sure
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the
say i've ever think
[Music]
pick yourself off the ground
yay
tell me
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he took
[Music]
new
it goes on and on and on
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
oh
give up
you